hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar entitled demonstrating value
health economics and laboratory medicine
my name is colleen string and i'll be
moderating today's session
on behalf of abbott and in partnership
with library
if you have any questions during the
session please simply type them into the
ask a question box and click send i'll
be reviewing them throughout
and there will of course be time at the
end of the presentation
questions as well should you experience
any technical difficulties
and or have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
please also use that same q a box
it is now my privilege to introduce
today's speaker
dr chris mccabe dr mccabe is the
executive director
and ceo of the institute of health
economics and brings more than 25 years
of experience
as a health economist to his role with
ihe
originally trained in the uk dr mccabe
held full profession
professorship at the universities of
sheffield
warwick and leeds and was more recently
a professor of health economics at the
university of
alberta where he was appointed capital
health endowed research chair
leading research groups focused on the
evaluation
adoption and implementation of precision
medicine technology
he has also served on the canadian
agency for drugs and technology and
healthcare's
health economics working group more
recently
dr mccabe advised the patented medicines
price review board
on the technical issues related to the
revision of the regulations for setting
the price
of new drugs in canada and he is
currently the care
of the royal society of canada coded
task force working group on the economy
welcome dr mccabe the stage is yours
thank you very much colleen and thank
you for the uh opportunity to speak to
you all today
uh so um
listening to that i i think um it's just
proof that if you hang around long
enough
you will get to do interesting things um
so today
um starting off with the disclosure they
we received ihe's received support uh
for today's work from abbott and
i'm making this presentation at the
request of abbott
i'm employed by the institute of health
economics and other than that i have
no conflicts of interest to declare uh
quick overview uh i'm going to talk a
little bit about
uh clinical testing and there's a quote
from the merch manual which kind of
uh is my touchstone for thinking about
clinical testing and
what it's all about so i i tend to start
presentations like that
with with a quote from from the merc
manual because i just think it's it's
it's always really useful to remember uh
that everything people like me do is to
try and
improve what happens in healthcare for
patients
and uh if we ever lose sight of that
then then we're
uh we're in the wrong job and we need to
go away and do something else uh
sorry i'll start with that quote i hope
you'll there with me
so i'm going to talk about uh test
evaluation pathway
a little bit uh because that you know
there's
there's been a lot of test evaluation
for for decades and and
there's some fantastic experts and i
want to just
highlight where health economics
i think really the new kid on the block
in this space
where it fits in uh and then i'll get
into
uh the the meat of the presentation
around
cost effectiveness analysis uh the the
most
immediately relevant part of the health
economic toolkit
uh and how cost effectiveness analysis
relates to this concept of value and how
we
uh how we can use cost effectiveness
analysis
to be confident that when we uh adopt
new technologies that they are actually
adding value to the health service to
the health system and therefore
thereby improving um outcomes for the
patients that we serve
then uh talk about uh value in
laboratory medicine
and there's a little bit of algebra
there but i'm not going to spend a great
deal of time on it
it's uh you know there's actually quite
a
a long standing body of methods for this
uh and and truth be told they've they've
not been widely used until precision
medicine
turned up and precision medicine has
really
uh brought those methods into their own
and so then i'm going to
you know outline those concepts how that
all works
and then talk very specifically about
value and precision medicine because
uh that that's where a lot of the the
hot button issues
uh in laboratory medicine and the
adoption of new technologies and
therefore
where people are looking for health
economics to see if we can help
uh resolve uh the questions and the
challenges
and then we'll have a uh some time for
uh questions from yourselves so do
please
put your questions uh in in the box
uh and um colleen will then
uh quiz me with them in that period so i
look forward to that
and i always learn things from the
questions that people ask me so
thanks a lot and we'll get on with the
presentation
so this is a session with manual uh and
i think the thing i i want to highlight
is uh you know
they i put them in highlighting them in
a sort of red color
so tests may help make a diagnosis in
symptomatic
patients or identify a called disease in
asymptomatic patients
laboratory tests are imperfect and
that's really important
to recognize that means that we
they are not free of harm okay doing a
test
carries a risk of harm to the patient
because it may give us the wrong answer
so we may get
both both positives and the other way
around
false negatives uh and we do things to
patients
in response to the results of tests uh
and we don't want to do things to
patients that
we won't benefit from them next thing it
says the test ability to correctly
include or exclude
disease depends on how likely a person
is to have a disease they call it the
prior probability
as well as the tests intrinsic operating
characteristics so
that the operating characteristics of
the test are portable and generalizable
to a fair degree
but the characteristics of populations
vary the prior probability of disease
varies across populations and so you
have to think about both
when you're thinking about uh the
performance of a test we
we can't just assume that because it
performs in well in one
population it's good value in one
population it's necessarily going to be
good value in another
um and and i i really like this final
bit
the diagnostic test is a critical
contributor to clinical decision making
testing can have undesired and
unintended consequences
and therefore testing must be done with
deliberation and purpose
and with the expectation that the test
result will be
reduce ambiguity and contribute to the
patient's health
so it shouldn't be automatic that a test
is ordered
there needs to be a critical clinical
thought process that leads to the
ordering of a test
so that you can explain why it's done so
this is the kind of foundation i try to
keep
in the back of my mind when i'm thinking
about tests and the evaluation of tests
so as i said a little earlier the
evaluation of tests has been going on a
long time
uh before health economics came on the
scene really
we're the new kids on the blocks uh we
you know
laboratories have long been interested
in analytic vitality their technical
performance
uh our tests um
they haven't thought so much about
measurement uncertainty but it's
becoming
more of an issue uh uncertainty in test
performance
uh that are driven by variations in
the analytic processes in the laboratory
are becoming
uh increasingly part of what is
considered and there are many
other components of test evaluation and
health economics this cost effectiveness
over here
is just one of them we've got you know
we're concerned about
measurement we turned about clinical
accuracy clinical utility
and then cost effectiveness and then the
broader implications
uh of the use of the tests so
you know we're healthy economics is only
one part of the uh
the test evaluation pathway and it's
very much the new kid on the block and i
think it's very
incumbent upon people like myself to
be suitably um
modest and cautious
in in statements about what we
understand and what we don't understand
there's
many disciplines and professionals
who've been working in this space
for a long time and it's incumbent upon
us to listen and learn from
and be very clear about what it is that
we add in a
in addition to their expertise and when
our expertise may or may not be relevant
because we're not always relevant
i mean you know it's we're not the
answer to everything strange to quite
know
economics generally and health economics
specifically is not
relevant to every question that we have
in a health policy space
and
and to be honest historically test
evaluations
by hta bodies like nice in the uk and
cardiff here in canada
have tended not to to look too much
inside the black box of laboratory
testing so
uh like a colleague of mine alison smith
at the university
the uk did a nice systematic review
uh and showed that acas um
only 19 of them identified some aspect
of
uh performance measurement in in
evaluating
the tests so now that really is uh quite
small
a low level of performance so you know
that
health economics reaching in inside the
black box of the laboratory and drawing
on the expertise of the people who have
worked in that space for a long time
it's something i think we need to do uh
we need to do better at that and so
one of the things i the reason i said
yes to this is it's an opportunity for
me as a health economist to reach out to
the laboratory medicine community
and and share what we do and how we
think about things
uh and have an opportunity to build
those relationships so that i can learn
from the community about what you do and
how you do it
and hopefully we can find points of
complementarity
uh where we can improve both
uh what we do and maybe contribute a
little bit to what you do
so when we think about measurement
uncertainty we're interested in
in precision precision and truth um
so the precision is about the closeness
of agreement between
repeated tests what the degree of random
error and i i really like this again
this is from my colleague allison smith
uh at the university of leeds in the uk
where we
you know ideally we want low levels of
imprecision
and low bias so here we have on the left
hand side we have a
you know that's our ideal test um
if we have imposition but low bias well
you know we got a great deal of
uncertainty but the expected value
it is still good uh so we're doing okay
on
on the truth the trueness of our of the
measure
uh we in some ways i worry most about
the the third one or the second from the
right hand side the low
imprecision and high bias because if you
don't know about the bias
you think you're very certain about the
test uh and that can give you great
confidence in doing the wrong thing
which
is almost the worst case scenario
uh and on the right-hand side we have uh
both imprecision and bias uh
and and that's well that's the lowest
level of performance from a decision
perspective
uh because you would seize a high level
of imprecision
uh in practice you you that that would
likely hurt caution so i i really like
this way
of thinking about precision and trueness
and how labs
think about uh you conventionally think
about uh
measurement uncertainty and test
performance uh and it's a really
important input
to value assessment but i think what
we're saying is health economics is you
know getting
low in precision and low bias that's not
the end of the story
to establish by the value we want that
and we want that as an input to the
process of establishing value
and you know health economics is really
all about value
okay next so apologies for people on
this
uh webinar who know this stuff i'm not
wasn't sure about the range of knowledge
and expertise of the
of the audience so i've uh i've included
some
pretty fun foundational things just to
make sure everyone's
uh on the same level and then we'll
build up from there
admittedly i'm going to build up pretty
quickly uh but
i i thought it was worth making sure we
have the same
shared uh basic building blocks uh
in place so what is economic evaluation
so economic evaluation
is the comparative analysis of
alternative courses of action
in terms of their costs and consequences
so it has to be comparative so it can't
just be one thing
and it has to consider both costs and
consequences
so a cost analysis is not an economic
evaluation
you know if you tell me how much
something costs
it's interesting if i was just an
accountant i'd be thrilled with that
piece of information
but i don't know whether it's good value
because i don't know what i get for that
cost
similarly reporting the costs and
outcomes of a single course of action
that's not an economic evaluation either
because i don't know whether
that is better or worse than the
alternative
and there is always an alternative doing
nothing
is always an option and doing nothing
will have
costs and consequences associated with
it
so an active intervention
if there's only one active intervention
we should still
ask ourselves does this
produce different outcomes and at what
additional cost
or cost saving possibly does does it do
so
compared to just doing nothing i i love
that that that that phrase
that educators uh in in medicine
i have a lot of colleagues who are
medical educators and they say one of
the hardest things
is is to to get doctors to understand
that you know sometimes their job is is
just to stand there
and do nothing you know we're naturally
called to intervene
you know that idea of don't just stand
there do something but actually
sometimes
just stand there and do nothing is the
better course of action
and an economic evaluation we want to
ask
whether that is the better course of
action in terms of its costs and
outcomes
but there's always a comparator so
economic evaluation
has to be comparative and it has to
consider both costs and consequences
of different actions
why do we need it well we need it
because
we do not have enough resources to
fulfill all of the needs
that we would want everything that
humanity we want to do
um you know the uh the estimate is we're
getting through resources on planet
earth
uh at about a rate that we need two and
a half planet earth
to sustain you know so we
we are not respecting scarcity very well
if we're realistic we we can't pay for
everything
so we have to make choices and therefore
we use this concept in economics called
opportunity cost really foundational
to the whole field of economics which is
the opportunity cost of an action is the
next
best use of the resources that are
consumed by that action
okay economic evaluation
aims to ensure that the benefits of
interventions or programs that we do
implement are greater than their
opportunity costs
you know so what we get is more valuable
than what we give up
and we do that to help target scarce
resources
where they will do what is most valuable
on this
quote from the world bank back in 1993
cost-effectiveness analysis is one form
of economic evaluation
broadly there are three forms there's
cost effectiveness analysis
where resource utilization is measured
using monetary
and monetary terms and the outcome is
measured in natural units clinical units
so uh
so life years changes in hba1c and
diabetes
uh changes in uh your blood pressure
measurement
uh changes in your cholesterol
uh those are all pure cost effectiveness
analysis
cost benefit analysis is is this form of
economic evaluation that's used
more broadly outside of health because
it
it puts a monetary value on the outcome
the effects
of an intervention and and for a long
time there's been a
a discomfort with putting a monetary
value
health on lives people in healthcare are
uncomfortable with that and so there's
been a reluctance to use cost benefit
analysis
in health and healthcare in the same way
that it's used
in other areas such as transport and
environments and defence and
education so uh health economics has
come up with a third form of economic
evaluation which is cost utility
analysis
um where obviously resource usage is
valued in monetary terms
but the outcomes are valued in terms of
the
of what we call utilities so the the
the preference for being in a particular
health state
uh and the duration of those that health
state so we
quality adjusted life years uh is the
summary measure used
in in uh in in cost utility analysis and
i'll
say a little bit more about uh those in
a moment
so cost utility analysis is so
widely used in economic evaluation in
health
that it's often referred to as
cost-effectiveness it's regarded as a
more sophisticated version of
cost frequency analysis comparisons
between interventions are
made in terms of the incremental cost
effectiveness ratio and i'll define that
shortly
uh effects are measured in terms of
healthy years
where and healthy years are captured on
this multi-dimensional
utility-based measures so utility just
think of it as
value or preference or satisfaction
okay um it combines
the duration of life with some judgment
about the quality
of your health during that time during
those years of life
and and you know i when i'm giving this
a presentation like this to purely
clinical audiences
i ask them what what does healthcare do
um and uh often i
i don't immediately get an answer and
then i'll say are there any doctors in
the audience surely
you know it is what it is that you do
and that you lead every day and there's
a little bit of
shuffling and then we get a discussion
going and we tend to arrive quite
comfortably that
you know what healthcare does is it
improves
our life expectancy and or
the quality of our life during that
period
and the the quality adjusted life year
is just an attempt
to to provide an index that conceptually
can capture the outcomes
of different types of healthcare so hip
replacements
versus culinary surgery versus
uh uh blood pressure measurement versus
chemotherapy
all of them are trying to uh
improve our quality of life and our
length of life
and and they're all calling on the same
health care budget
so we need a single measure of benefit
of outcome of effect
in order to identify which are producing
the most benefit per dollar spent
uh so as i said that's the quality
adjusted life here conceptually what it
is
um and the utility utility is a measure
of preference
uh and it it it sits on this scale
where uh full health or perfect health
is given a value of one
dead or health states where you would
be indifferent between continuing to
live in that health state and being dead
are given a value of zero and health
states that are worse than death you
know
we know this some people who find
themselves in health states where they
say
say i would rather be dead than remain
in this health state
well those are are are given a negative
value
okay and we combine the utility values
then the weight that we apply to the
survival data
to produce qualities so it's a really
simple
illustration imagine you you've got a
health problem
your current health state has a utility
of 0.5 and your life expectancy is two
years
so that means without intervention you
expect to
live another quality to receive one
quality
over the remainder of your life if you
undergo the operation
your health state utility increases to
0.9 your life expectancy expands to 5
years
and that means you'll get 4.5 points
your expectation
if you have the operation is another 4.5
qualities
over your five years of life expectancy
so the quality gain from the operation
is 3.5 and here it is graphically
and this is just to highlight actually
incremental qualities are just the
difference in the area
of quality adjusted life expectancy
because obviously
survival curves don't take these sort of
ships yeah
but just to illustrate that that's
actually what we're doing
we're just exp extrapolating or
predicting
life expectancy with a quality
adjustment
for uh the actual health over that life
expectancy
and then calculating the difference in
the area under the curves
to capture the benefit of the
intervention
which i think is intuitively a
reasonable thing to do
so talks about cost effectiveness ratios
cost effectiveness ratio presents the
average cost effectiveness
of an intervention so if the total costs
of the intervention
divided by the total qualities
from that intervention we're not
actually interested in a cost
effectiveness ratio
because that's not comparative what
we're
interested in is the incremental cost
effectiveness ratio
which we uh you know if that's the
that's the comparative the way that we
make sure an economic evaluation is
comparative
so we often call this the isa and it's
quite simply
the difference in the expected costs
between the two interventions
divided by the difference in the
qualities between the two interventions
so it's a really simple concept and and
it is just asking
for every additional unit every
additional quality
how much extra money do we have to spend
okay
so that's all it is it's you know if you
know how much more you have to spend
and how much more health you get for it
then you can make a judgment
about whether the additional health is
worth the additional
expenditure okay
so now i want to talk to you about how
we use
this incremental cost effectiveness
ratio
to make sure that our reimbursement
decisions
are coherent with uh maximizing the
value
that we get from our limited health care
budget so
i'm going to start off with asking you
to imagine a really
simple small health care system
and i want this is a value proposition
okay
the value proposition is that
interventions that produce more health
per thousand dollars
spent a better value than those that
produce
less okay so that's a value proposition
if you don't accept that
then you will not accept the cost
effectiveness analysis is a good way
to allocate limited health care
resources
the other thing that we have to accept
is that the health system has a limited
budget
if you think that resources are not
scarce then
again you won't accept the need for cost
effectiveness analysis
or economics at all in fact so uh
what i'm going to do is this health
system produces a
provides a a portfolio of technologies
but eventually that portfolio of
technologies exhaust the available
budget
i just want to highlight something
important here
and again this is a value proposition
if we are going to adopt a new
technology
it should produce
at least as much health per thousand
dollars spent
as the least valuable the least
efficient technology that we currently
provide
okay so this is our operation
operationalization of the idea of
opportunity cost
a if we adopt a new technology what we
give up
this technology we should give up the
least valuable technology that
produces the least health in order to
pay for it
or at least help per thousand dollars
spent in order to pay for it
so now we've we've always got treatments
that aren't covered
and which patients and manufacturers
would like us to cover
and using that decision rule uh we can
quickly say okay well
this one's worse than the current least
valuable
as is this one and so we don't need to
worry about them we can say no to them
and we'll get rid of them so they're
gone
but these two they're clearly better
than the
than this one so let's adopt the first
one
so move it from that side and into that
side
and there you go in it goes
hopefully slightly slower animation than
i'm used to
uh doing it on the web platform but
that's okay a couple of things
one we have had to display some care
because the budget is fixed
to pay for this technology we've had to
displace in someone else's healthcare
so when people say it's money
and my life is worth more than that
amount of money
yes but the money is somebody else's
healthcare
so when we adopt a new technology
and the budget isn't increased to cover
the complete cost of that
then we are displacing somebody's else's
healthcare we don't know who's
in practice but we know it is happening
things we currently spend at the support
have to be given up
in order to pay for the new technology
that doesn't mean it's the wrong
decision
it's just that's the reality we've
adopted this one because it's
better it produces more health per
thousand dollars spent
than this one than what we had to give
up so that's a reasonable thing to do
we still this we have a new worst
least valuable technology and this one
is still better than that so we should
adopt that too
the same process we displace
current expense current healthcare to
pay for the new
because it produces more health per
thousand dollars spent
and we can see that we now have a new
opportunity cost a new measure what we
have to give up
but importantly we can also see
but the total health produced from the
expenditure of the budget
is greater than it was before we made
these changes
so health population health from the
available budget
has been increased if we want the
opportunity cost for next decisions to
be lower
we need to increase our budget now
you'll know i've talked about this
measure of opportunity cost as health
benefit per thousand dollars spent
that's the inverse you can flip that
round and you can say
it's the cost per unit of health benefit
but what this is what this opportunity
cost is
what we in everyday discussions talk
about as being the cost effectiveness
threshold or our willingness to pay for
health
the fifty thousand dollars per quali
okay so
flip this measure around as its inverse
and express this as as the the cost
effectiveness threshold it's essentially
the same thing
so when we talk about using a cost
effectiveness threshold
to decide whether we adopt or don't
adopt a new technology whether it's a
test or anything else
we're talking about ensuring that the
new technology
produces more health per thousand
dollars spent
than the technologies that we have to
give up to pay for it
so that's the link between cost
effectiveness analysis
and value in the health system
we can increase the value we get from
our
limited healthcare system budget by
using
cost-effectiveness thresholds to inform
our which technologies get adopted
and which don't okay so that's
i kind of found the the foundation of
uh of what we're about and uh
okay so thinking about lab tests and
test directed care
so the good news is
how you apply cost effectiveness
analysis to
um to test technologies
uh has been figured out for a long time
so
this lovely paper from phelps and muslim
back in 1988
that set out how to optimize a test
to hit a cost effectiveness target
uh and here's the algebra for anyone who
wants to
subsequently have a look through it uh
you can
look at the paper but the really central
thing is
as we move the as we change the the the
the test performance criteria the
sensitivity and the specificity
we changed the cost effectiveness of a
test
and what felts and muslims showed
was the optimal cut point
for a test from a cost-effective
specific perspective
is where the gradient of the roc curve
the receiver operating characteristic
is the same as the slope of the cost
effectiveness threshold
so if you think cost effectiveness
threshold is an incremental cost
effectiveness
it's a ratio and so it has a slope you
know it has a gradient
where the gradient of the roc and the
gradient of the threshold
are the same that's your optimum cut
point and so we
this is from their paper uh you know two
alternative cut points
showing how the optimal cut point is
different depending
upon your cost effectiveness threshold
okay
and just to think through a little bit
about what's happening there
is when you change your cut point you
change the proportion of false negative
and uh
false positive cases that you get
and so you you change how many tests
lead to actions which either are not
valuable
or could be harmful so the value of a
test
is driven by the actions it triggers and
how they change the health outcomes for
the patient
that's what it's about and and if we
change the quick point
we change the proportion of tests where
the action will have no or negative
value
okay
so let's talk about precision medicine a
little bit
so decision medicine technologies are
highly heterogeneous so to talk about
physician medicine i think is sometimes
really unhelpful it's an umbrella but
there's a whole
bunch of technologies under that so
we can just have a molecular test you
know that's
uh diagnostic or that might be screening
or might be monitoring
that's a precision medicine technology
and it may just provide information
we can also have molecular tests and
increasingly do have molecular tests
that are linked to a specific treatment
especially in cancer
where we're looking at does the tumor
have this specific characteristic
this particular molecular signature and
if so
we're confident the treatment targets
that molecular signature
we could have a phenotypic test
which we then follow up with a
pharmacogenomic test
which then could lead to treatment
we can have a molecular tests you know
that
leads to a pharmacogenomic test that
leads to treatment so if you think
of um black
uh driven cancers
you might do the molecular tests to
guide the treatment
you men might do pharmacokin you know
a genetic test to establish whether it's
a a a
an inherited form of the cancer and if
it's an inherited form of trans
the treatment may change you know you
more aggressive surgery
um you know ovarian cancer or breast
cancer for an example
uh what i'm trying to get people to
understand is
in precision medicine there are a lot of
these tests and each test
has this complexity of the true positive
false positive true negative false
negative
which feeds in either to a treatment but
it can feed into another test
phenotypic test or a pharmacogenomic
test
and they all have these uncertainties
which drive differences in
outcomes and costs and and when you
change
the the the definition the case
definition the cut point on the test or
wanted
a description it all feeds through to
differences
in the outcomes of
uh of the treatment pathway
and we need to start thinking about this
quite carefully
and understanding that if we want to um
maximize our access to these effective
therapies
then it's not just about playing with
the price it's not just about playing
with the budget that's available
we also have the ability to modify
the test positive and negative case
definitions
to drive different value propositions
through the system
and and the challenge of these
technologies is so
that i i really think we have to use all
the tools that are available to us
and not you leave one or two of them on
the side
because well they they use this case
definition in the us
or in europe so we have to use the same
one
well that's not necessarily true i think
we need to recognize
that when we're trying to get value
and we're dealing with a health system
with a budget and a given set
of demands on that budget which are
driven by the epidemiology of disease
in the population they serve and
historical factors about how the
available budget is allocated
and differences in the efficiency of the
health systems
that we can't just say well
this is the price this is the definition
take it or leave it
for maximizing health and access and
impact of these
fascinatingly valuable potentially
valuable new technologies
we need to be willing to use all of the
uh
the tools in our toolbox we need to be
willing to change
the test cut point if that enables us
to get to a value of the test
and subsequently and strategies that is
affordable and attractive to the health
system that we're
that we're working within um
you can't there is it is unhelpful to
point to other
uh health systems which have different
budgets and different needs and
priorities
and say well they're paying for it
therefore you should pay for it
i i you know that's not sustainable as a
strategy to promote
the efficient use of our limited health
resources
uh we we can't say it's fixed it's
untouchable
it's not it's a decision we make and
it's a decision that we can make
informed by
deficiency so
optimum use of precision medicine will
be health system specific
it will require synthesis of what is
often often currently siloed data
between the diagnostic
uh genetics effectiveness and
epidemiology
we're going to have to be a lot better
at bringing all of that evidence to bear
in evaluating and optimizing but if it's
done right
i think we will see precision medicine
both increase population health
and impact in a good way on health care
system expenditures
so i'm just going to do a quick example
to show you what i think is
possible and there's a publication that
people go away and read if they wish to
so individuals clinical pathways
are frequently determined by the
sequential use of one or more tests
you know diabetes they you know
test their blood sugar every you know
few hours not hourly
and you know you'll get monthly recalls
back to your family doctors
check check your blood pressure um
testing and repeated testing and
monitoring is
a crucial and highly frequent event in
healthcare
um that's muslin said here's how you
optimize it for a single decision point
a single point in time
but actually we needed to extend this
for sequential testing
um remember the quote from the merc
manual that says
a test ability to correctly include all
excellent disease depends upon
how likely a person is to have that
disease the prior probability
as well as the test intrinsic
characteristics well
your first test result will often you
know it will divide
your initial population into two groups
the positive and the negative
and therefore at the second test
administration you will often have a
different prior probability
and that gives us an opportunity to
start
uh being a bit more efficient maybe to
optimize sequential testing for value
so this is the conventional sql
sequential strategy
same cut points for everybody at the
same time points
but what we did was we uh we we said
okay what if we
try to recognize the change in the prior
probability between the positives and
the negatives
after the first at the time of the
second administration
of a test what does that do
for both of them we've got two groups
different prior probabilities how does
that change things
uh and this is jumping to the end of the
story so to speak to make sure that
there's time for any questions you may
have
um what you find is that
the optimal test point this is
uh for um a test for monitoring
uh the risk of testicular cancer if i
remember correctly
because it's about eight years ago that
we did this now uh
the both the test cut point
and the optimal interval
between testing changes
and so instead of you know if we go back
to this where we have
everyone being tested six times
we can
test these people at month three and
what we do subsequently for them
will be uh informed by the new prior
probabilities
but these people we don't need to test
them
until month five so there is
a personalization in terms of the burden
of accessing health care
on the patient you know our demands of
them
is significantly lower because we looked
to optimize the tests
are on value plans
and the total number of tests is
significantly lower
so the health system saves money uh
and remember as i said earlier it's not
money it's somebody else's healthcare
so it's not that that money is going to
be given back to the insurance company
or it's going to be given back to the
government
uh if it's money that's in the budget
that's going to be used
to pay for other people's health care
their needs
which may be tests which may be test
directed treatments
maybe screening or maybe just family
doctor visits
or reducing the waiting lists for hip
replacements or reducing the waiting
list from uh
channel adolescent mental health support
you know
it's not money money is just a mechanism
for
moving resources around the health
system so when we make a financial
saving
we're actually producing health for
other people
and that's got to be a good thing to do
and so
getting really personal
about optimizing healthcare in the
testing component of healthcare
i think it is a massive opportunity for
us and and that
places laboratory medicine and people
like yourselves and
the products that you produce at the
forefront
if you want to be there of uh increasing
the efficiency
of the healthcare system uh so
i find that exciting i i i hope you do
too
so it's efficient to use the information
in earlier tests to identify both test
intervals and test cut points
for subsequent uh clinical management
test guided management can personalize
care and maximize the value of the
health that's produced
which seems to me like a win-win
situation for everyone involved
summarize adopting a value-based
approach so using cost-effectiveness
analysis and acknowledging limited
resources
to optimize that test direct care
including precision medicine
can facilitate sustainable adoption in
recall
resource constrained health systems and
by the way all health systems are recall
resource constrained there is a limit to
every health systems budget
what happens when that limit is breached
is how they differ in private insurance
systems
what happens is the um the premiums go
up
and some people can no longer afford
those premiums
and therefore they are excluded from
healthcare
or they can only afford a cheaper so
they don't have access to the same
portfolio
in publicly funded social
taxation-funded healthcare systems
when we reach the budget we have waiting
lists
so we ration by time or we ration by
socioeconomic status
there is no version in which we don't
ration
adopting a value-based approach to
personalizing healthcare can release
further resources to invest
in addressing currently unmet needs uh
and that's kind of why i'm in this game
that's that's what drives me
uh to do the work i do
so just a quick plug a little advert at
the end
uh we're partnering universe of
healthcare excellence program
uh you won't be surprised given what i
just said that i see
the the relationship between laboratory
medicine and health economics
as a key driver and a key opportunity to
improve healthcare
both quality and sustainability in the
future
and in and univac's health direction
program we got involved
when we were invited because we see it
as uh
one way that we can move that
relationship forward one way we can
support
uh efficiency and quality in healthcare
uh within laboratory medicine so uh
that's our little advert plug over
and i will uh i'll stop talking
at you and hopefully start talking
with you and we can uh now happy to
answer any questions that you have
[Music]
thank you doctor for that wonderful
presentation
on what is clearly an important
and relevant topic in in not just
laboratory medicine but in health care
today
we can all appreciate not just the
importance of a laboratory test
such within the laboratory but its
downstream affects
um on processes and decision making
downstream
and the importance of being able to
really measure um
what those insights do for for decision
making so
thank you so much for for a very
relevant presentation
on a very important topic um especially
as
uh first which is the opening of the
universal healthcare excellence award
third cycle is opening um so it's a very
timely presentation to hear
an important topic as really being able
to have that strong measurements
associated with
changes and costs um is a key driver for
not only decision making and change
but also uh this prestigious program
which you are
a wonderful and valued partner for
and so with that we will open up the
session
for some questions and we actually have
a few that have already come in
and so the first is actually
so measuring the value of new processes
which is often what lab insights enable
can be very difficult
versus say measuring the value of a
device
based on the information you provided
and your experience
what is the best approach for actually
measuring the cost
and change association a process
great question great question so there's
no
one-size-fits-all uh answer to this
question how do you best
uh measure the resource implications
of a new process is
it will be health system specific um and
what we tend to do is we try to do it
early
and so we start with talking to the
the clinicians who will be using the
information
and tell us what they think they will do
in response to the information and and
let's be honest
the more they use the test the more they
learn and they change what they do
so it's not a one and done process but
we we have that
uh ideally we get a you know a consensus
clinical consensus group together and to
to get agreement
on what they think they're going to do
given
the health system context that they work
in okay
and then once they've told that we can
then work behind the scenes to
to figure out what the resource
implications and the cost of those
resource implications
are one thing that's really useful in
that process
is you will get insights into the the
differences between what i think of as
the
the the early mid and late adoptions
you know so there will be a time at
which you will have the new process
trying to run in parallel with the old
processor and depending upon the
the the risk attitude what's better
phrase of your clinical community
in that space uh that the length of that
dual process
uh will will vary and those are you know
those are legitimate transaction costs
that we need to think about
whilst we're whilst we're uh running the
implementation
so i think what we do is we try to
figure that out
but then you monitor uh it's really
important not to think of this
as a one-and-done the best indicator
of what is going to happen is got
in those first few months of monitoring
what
does happen what i have found and
it kind of sounds obvious really but but
doctors are incredibly bright people
and they're incredibly good at working
around the system to still do what they
want to do whether that's to be an
earlier doctor or a later doctor or what
and so observing what is happening and
updating your predictions so if you're
informing a decision maker a budget
holder
having shared with them that early
monitoring plan
so you say look this is what everybody
says this is what we think will happen
but these are the things we're going to
do to monitor
so that we can flag up to you
if the expected trajectory on the cost
side of things
and if things are rapidly enough in
process the expected trajectory
on the outcome side of things aren't
being observed
so you wanna equip the decision maker
whoever the budget holder is
with with some risk management tools so
do your best to describe what you expect
to happen
given the clinician's uh
perspective and the knowledge and
evidence about the technology and
the other components of the process but
don't do a one-and-done
um you know we we we had a an evaluation
not too long ago with a
a test for breast cancer
to guide therapy and breast cancer and
because we monitored what was actually
able to happen
we the decision maker actually hit pause
on the attempt to change practice
after about 12 months because the amount
of money that was being spent
on the exceptional review
uh to try and you know the doctors were
using to keep doing what they were
determined to keep doing
uh completely wiped out any savings in
the long run so if we sustained it we'd
have made a you know a net loss
even though the evidence said you should
do x y and z and the doctor said oh yes
we'll do it quick finder
what they actually did which was
in their mind what they thought was best
for their patients meant that it wasn't
worth persisting
the benefit of the change was completely
eaten up by the transaction cost of the
change as the doctors work their way
around it so i hope that's answered the
question you had
it's a it's a very good
highlights a few key points of course
the importance of
continuously measuring but also the
importance of getting stakeholder buy-in
when you're looking to change
processes uh changing processes or tests
or
or what have you in silos doesn't always
have the net effect
and so it's it's actually a fantastic
point to bring up
in light of your your second last slide
with the
healthcare excellence award program
which really
to celebrate those teams who have not
just made a measurable impact
but unified beyond their their small
silos
and and work together as teams to have
those measurable impacts it's
a wonderful point that you bring up um
and and really
highlights the importance of measurement
and and working together
as teams so thank you very much
now i think we probably have time for
one possibly two more questions
like you've piqued the interest from
from teams all over the world
so your next question is is there aid
relating to
achieving better health economic
evaluation in third world countries
so there is uh uh both the
uh there's an organization called inata
the international
network of hca agencies and
health technology assessment
international and just
recently the world health organization
have moved
into having creating a focus on
hta support to support the development
of hga
capacity uh in
low and middle income countries and so
what
i can do is i can send
if i send the information the link
through to you colleen can you
share that uh with the attendees so that
uh
we can you know that they know where to
look but yeah it's uh
it's an increasingly important priority
uh and
you know important organizations are
starting to put resources around helping
it happen well
outstanding wonderful well it sounds
like we have time for
one more question um and so
um this question is the need for a
comparator
um is or a baseline can sometimes be
very difficult
for example knowing that that thousand
dollars per health benefit
um do you have any suggestions or best
practices for getting that
baseline in sure a comparator is readily
available for a health economic
evaluation
so if you have access to
routine data if you're in a health
system that has
access that enables you to have access
to routine data
looking at the data to identify what
happens to the patients
who who have the clinical indication is
really useful i think
you know we we've got into this in the
uh the rare diseases space
where you know patients go on these uh
diagnostic odysseys through the health
system before they
they finally arrive at a definitive
diagnosis
and and so uh that you know that's
what we have uh tended to do to
uh to look in the routine data
if you haven't got routine data then you
you're stepping back in terms of the
robustness of the information
to use expert opinion get the clinicians
the clinical teams to tell you what
happens
but don't just there's good and bad ways
of doing that
okay so uh the more that's at stake the
bigger the budget and play for the
decision
the more it's worth looking at some
formal
uh expert elicitation methods
where you that they're the structured
question processes
that allow you to get quantitative
expressions of their expert beliefs
so they don't they don't just tell you
well we do x
they tell you the probability that
they'll do x
and the uncertainty around that
probability
which gives you information you can
directly embed
in your decision analytic model so
again there's some nice literature
around using expert elicitation
in places where there isn't evidence and
i again i'll share
a couple of uh links with colleen
around that uh methods set
and and colleen will send them all to
everybody
wonderful thank you so much dr mccabe
and thank you again for
for the wonderful presentation um it
looks like we are out of
time um we do have some additional
questions that have been coming in
and so rest assured your questions will
be answered um
through email
um and so i'd like to thank you for
joining us today
i would like to thank labruz as well as
ihe a brilliant partner of the
university healthcare excellence award
program
which was founded in partnership with
several other
societies around the world that are
leaders in transformational health care
and so to close and really help wrap up
this presentation
which really highlights the importance
of measurement
key stakeholders including the payer we
invite
anyone on this call as well as other
interrelated clinical care teams to
visit the university of healthcare
excellence award website
and if you do have any questions please
contact
the the administrative portal um for any
questions
as as it's a very relevant and important
award program that's grown substantially
in the last three years and so if there
are any questions related to that please
do also
reach out and you can also visit uh
the universal healthcare excellence
award website and or ihe
um for more information and so before we
go
um i'll just say thank you again to dr
mccabe and to iet for their wonderful
partnership with the program and
wonderful presentation
today thank you so much thanks everyone
it's been a real pleasure